in terms of crowds and physical exertion
some people say Hajj is a bit like the
Olympics but unlike the Olympics a
decision on whether this year's Hajj
will go ahead is still up in the air
that decision lies with Saudi Arabia the
custodian of Islam's holiest site in
Makkah where two and a half million
Muslims travel for a journey of a
lifetime I took a gap year from you need
to do a placement so I could say but for
me you know it's a really important part
of my faith so it's a really a big shame
that we couldn't go this year I can't go
ahead naveen is among some 25,000
British Muslims who will see their
travel plans canceled in the likely
event that the Saudis declare Hajj off
this year's calendar it'll cost the UK
travel industry an estimated hundred and
seventy-five million pounds in losses
we've had no activity for the last three
months the last booking that we received
was sometime in March after lockdown and
knocked down in South Korea bookings
died down the financial statements this
year aren't gonna be looking very good
this was meant to be Saudis big year
hosting the g20 gathering of world
leaders as it attempts to move away from
being an oil dependent economy it's
already opened itself up to tourism
concerts and glitzy sporting events but
having eased lockdown measures at the
end of May it's now seeing a second wave
of new coronavirus infections forcing it
to consider canceling its biggest event
one that generates nearly 5 billion
pounds in revenue every year
I think this Saudi authorities are very
keen for Hajj to go ahead however they
need to do this in a very safe and
protected money the program it's
industry the second biggest revenue
stream for the Saudi authorities so they
wouldn't have taken this lightly Muslim
leaders are urging the community to see
this not as a loss but as a sacrifice
look after yourself but be mindful of
the one next to you also and that is
really really very important so
therefore what I would like to say to my
beloved brothers and sisters who made
intentions of undertaking this lifetime
journey you've not lost anything if it
is cancer
the UK Foreign Office advises against
all non-essential travel it says it's
monitoring the global travel situation
closely
Sadia Chaudhary Sky News